[Musica]
cari amici vicini e lontani quando i
miei genitori erano giovani c'era un
conduttore televisivo che scavavano un
suo filogamo che iniziava sempre ogni
suo saluto così
buonasera cari amici vicini e lontani
erano tempi molto diversi da quelli di
oggi
allora non c'erano i cellulari non
c'erano neanche le reti informatiche e
al limite se mia madre mi doveva cercare
a parlare o usava il telefono per
chiamarmi a scuola o dagli amici dove mi
trovavo oppure magari erano apriva la
finestra e mi chiamava in cortile oggi è
tutto molto diverso la nostra società è
molto diversa siamo tutti interconnessi
siamo tutti legati gli uni agli altri da
una rete di connessioni diverse e
molteplici siamo tutti davanti e degli
schermi degli schermi che ci connettono
agli altri che ci dividono dagli altri
lo abbiamo visto in questo periodo di
pandemia
sicuramente non abbiamo mai usato tanto
la rete come in questo periodo è
sicuramente se non l'avessimo fatto ci
saremmo sentiti soli isolati maffi
chiusi in casa sequestrati tutti quanti
noi non siamo il social votiamo facebook
troviamo tweet che usiamo instagram
tutti i nostri dati vengono consegnati a
questi questi grandi dell'high tech
mondiale che lucrano alle nostre spalle
in qualche modo come loro con le nostre
profilazioni con in dati delle nostre
vite quindi nostri gusti nastri laiche
di youlike loro fanno mille alti ma
oltre a questo c'è un altro vero
pericolo in questa interconnessione
senza limiti che stiamo vivendo che
badate bene la cosa molto positiva una
cosa che ha portato in evoluzione
tantissimi vantaggi
ci sono i crimini informatici crimini
informatici vengono perpetrati spesso
proprio grazie al clima di grandissima
sorveglianza a cui noi tutti siamo
sottoposti calcola che nel 2019 si siano
stati compiuti 200 mila crimini
informatici con circa 4.000 persone
indagate
faremo subito di truffe truffe che non
sono più soltanto quello che era una
volta il vecchio phishing che arrivava
una media che sembrava venire dalla sua
banca e ti chiedeva di dare il suo
benestare una serie di operazioni che
poi si rivelavano il prosciugamento del
tuo conto in banca no sono cose molto
più sottili molto più subdole tutti noi
siamo felici di essere molto popolari
sul web di avere tantissimi migliaia di
follower però anche questo ha un
rovescio della medaglia
e se i popolani vuol dire anche essere
molto conosciuti vuol dire che gli altri
sanno tutto di te e qui nasce il tipo di
crimine informatico che è stato chiamato
dall fbi virtual kidnapping rapimento
virtuale sequestro virtuale di virtuale
a soprattutto all'inizio
l'esordio cioè quando le vittime vengono
adescate che spesso attraverso la rete
si tratta di un tipo di truffa
informatica di vero e proprio crimine
che e soprattutto comune in cina del
perché in cina perché le persone sono
molto più prone ad ascoltare il proprio
governo hanno più paura reverenziale nei
confronti delle autorità
e cosa succede succede che solitamente
si tratta di due vittime una vittima a
una vittima b c'è una vittima a che di
solito è quella che dovrebbe poi
compiere effettivamente il sequestro che
viene indottrinata parte vittima ricambi
non si devono mai parlare devono essere
contattati e
la distanza e non devono soprattutto
essere all'oscuro di quello di quello
che l'uno fa e l'altro spesso si dice ci
racconta queste vittime che
l'interlocutore è un agente dei servizi
segreti un agente governativo comunque
una persona delle autorità che devono
mettere una persona in sicurezza
probabilmente un testimone scomodo o in
altri casi non sarebbe successo anche
sono state vere e proprie minacce di far
del male ai genitori di questa persona
altrimenti non avrebbero avrebbero
lasciati stare si sono verificati anche
casi di persone spesso ragazze che alla
fine di questa operazione mandavano alla
foto di se stessi sequestrati quindi
legati con i polsi ammanettati o con
delle bende diritura gli occhi per
simulare il proprio rapimento
dopodiché una volta che il sequestratore
suoi sequestratori perché spesso di date
di bande che ti spillano prima che prima
ancora di conco incominciare a compiere
un'azione una volta che l'azione viene
compiuta di solito vengono incassati i
soldi spesso si dà ovviamente un numero
di conto corrente
spariscono nel nulla così come erano
arrivarci
ora però bisogna conoscere se stessi per
conoscere il proprio nemico come diceva
su nell'arte della guerra conoscere se
stessi vuol dire conoscere le proprie
debolezze quindi capire quali sono i
punti deboli a cui il sole che tu credi
di conoscere che in realtà sono dei
perfetti sconosciuti stanno cercando di
sfruttare a loro vantaggio può essere
appunto l'amore familiare una passione
sempre dei lati deboli più subdoli delle
particolari
cose che noi abbiamo che soltanto non lo
sappiamo e poi ci sono i nostri nemici
nostri amici più magari e sono spesso
dei volti che ci sembrano familiari che
si nascondono tra i nostri follower tra
i nostri pseudo amici che magari
conosciamo di noi ma non abbiamo mai
visto e che magari non corrispondono
affatto alle foto che hanno messo su
facebook
quindi ecco per tutelarsi sicuramente la
cosa migliore è sempre conoscere se
stessi sicuramente per capire quali
possono essere le proprie debolezze ma
anche cercare di capire chi si nasconde
dietro i falsi amici e molto spesso noi
abbiamo perché dubito che chiunque di
noi conosco al 5 mila persone su
facebook che poi il limite massimo che
viene concesso quando cerchiamo di
conoscerci meglio che forse in questo
modo riusciremo anche a capire quali
sono i nuovi rischi che dovremo
affrontare